it makes me sad that I have to attack
you in a good way ideas are you agree
with that statement Josie you Zach do
you agree with that yeah ideas are who
says I ever thought it was a necessary
call to action because the answer is I
didn't and I don't know I don't know I
didn't I can't write verse ah the truth
is my man there might be just a
situation where you're just not good at
closing hey [ __ ] I work both put on
the right I always ask why why why would
you want why would you want to own it
the why why do you want it to Trent why
not both Nick I don't know if you've
been paying attention to what I've been
screaming about for the last 100 days
but if you heard gotta show askgaryvee
subscribe so i'm putting out content for
awareness popping out hard core content
today i talked about being a great right
hooker and to build relationships with
all of you that's what i'm doing and
then engaging engaging engaging win a
free crown if you subscribe to this show
you understand i'm doing there Randy
right I don't like how hard I have to
throw right hooks to establish the base
by this friggin rare toy it's 999 buy it
now so I've got your number we got them
this time guys we got them so everybody
who's watching I need you to subscribe
up um you with a little bit of me we're
changing the QA world whether they like
it or not I appreciate the patience and
I'll see you soon subscribe
you